he's an average guy and he doesn't know
why people think he's a prophet cuz he's
not Mohammed that's me
now this next comedian wants everybody
to know that he is not Mohammed so
everybody please give a loud round of
applause for not Mohammed thank you I
love this town don't you hate it when
you have three wives and they don't
listen to you so you have to beat them
harder it's been another day in the life
of the guy with nine wives but don't be
mistaken cuz he's not Mohammed that's me
[Music]
welcome to the countdown as always I am
teacher Berman and I love Maybelline
maybe he's born with it maybe it's
Maybelline now many of you are aware of
my feud with the staggeringly
unintelligent conservative creighton
known as Glenn Beck after Glenn Beck
tweeted on what is commonly referred to
as the Internet to his followers that
they help him dig up some dirt on Cass
Sunstein mark Lloyd and Carol Browner I
decided to ask my viewers to find dirt
on Glenn Beck himself see I do Jitsu the
whole situation on the man I'm a black
belt
of course I expected to find dirt on the
man but what I did not expect was the
inflow of such nauseatingly thick grime
that it rivaled the build-up of Bronx
sewage drinks everyone knows the
boroughs are for losers
take for example the fact that Glenn
Beck knowingly poured orange juice in
the winter boot of Clarice MacDougall in
his second grade or for instance the
time at the Warsaw Hotel in Manhattan
where he calculatingly failed to tip his
chambermaid mr. Beck in your warped
dimension of a world do ladies of ethnic
origin deserve Nora to ax T is there no
end to your bigotry sir surprisingly I
managed to find in a cursed
segregationist self-professed fan of mr.
Beck who is here with us now mr. Alfonso
Rachel you you're off you're a black man
can't put anything past you man hey did
you know I'm an American too and you
support mr. Beck I don't agree with
everything that he says but for the most
part yeah
yeah okay can we just can we cut this
you guys can we get rid of that one I'm
not feeling comfortable with this
dynamic here can we take it from the
from the bigotry line hey is there no
end to your bigotry sir
here to comment is MSNBC's own Rachel
MANET well I agree with you Keith
you're so smart thank you Rachel and I
agree w t come on you guys really a
black conservative guess what are we
doing here what are we doing